the Poincare conjecture is what I'd like
to talk about and it is one of seven
kind of maths questions maths problems
which were picked by the Clay Institute
in well in the year 2000 as kind of the
the biggest outstanding problems in
maths the kind of real massive
unanswered questions and they they
picked a list of seven things and for
each one there is a million dollar prize
that they literally have that money
waiting for people and of these seven
problems only one of them so far has
been solved and it was the Poincare
conjecture
so the Poincare conjecture which was put
up by Poincare a and I forget around the
turn of the last century around 1900 was
a particular conjecture as a guess and
we were and he claimed that there were
these certain relationships between
geometry and topology so I can try and
explain a little bit about what the
Poincare conjecture is it's from an area
of matter called topology which is to do
with kind of shape and how things fit
together in space but it's essentially
about spheres so a common idea in
topology is the idea of deforming things
so I've got here a cube which is made
out of dough and in topology we can sort
of kind of move things around a little
bit it's sometimes called rubber sheet
geometry so I could take this cube and I
could kind of mess around with it and I
could round it off like that using my
hands and I can get a sphere pretty much
near enough so that's that the sphere
the the theory is that you're allowed to
to squash things stretch things and all
that kind of thing but you're not
allowed to push punch holes in things
you're not allowed to make a hole and
you're not allowed to close up a hole so
because of this the number of holes that
something has is very important so this
sphere has zero holes I guess you could
also have something like this doughnut
which has exactly one hole in it and you
can't get from a sphere to a doughnut by
deforming it without kind of closing up
this hole or by cutting it here and
straightening it out and squashing that
sausage into a sphere and you're not
allowed to cut and you're not allowed to
stick so the the kind of things that are
different from each other spheres are
different from Donuts which are
different again from like a pretzel with
two holes in it or something with three
holes in it or
any number of holes this is the kind of
maths that I studied a university for a
very long time and did some very
difficult math sun-soaked Ankara was a
French mathematician who posed this
conjecture he suggested that if you have
an object which doesn't have any holes
in it so first condition no holes second
condition is that it is kind of small
it's not it doesn't go on forever in any
direction so it's it's kind of finite
you could maybe put it in a box and
close the lid then it's a sphere or at
least it can be made into a sphere and
in two dimension while in three
dimensions which is where we live this
seems like a fairly sensible statement
but Poincare a suggested that this would
hold in any number of dimensions so you
can take this is a three-dimensional
sphere but you could have a
two-dimensional sphere will be a circle
you can also go up and have a
four-dimensional sphere which you'd have
to pretty much imagine but it's it's
sort of a sphere with an extra dimension
it's it's got a fixed radius in this one
has a fixed radius in three different
directions but the four-dimensional
sphere has another direction in which
it's still this size and any number of
dimensions above that and then you know
it's it's counterproductive to try and
imagine those things because it really
does hurt your brain but this conjecture
exists as a mathematical statement and
he posed this in the 1900s but didn't
have a proof for it and the the actual
proof of this took quite a long time so
the 1960s and 70s
lots of topology was happening what some
people were developing new tools for
doing topology and they managed to prove
during that time the case of five
dimensions and above but there was still
four dimensional spheres to think about
and this was sort of still unsolved and
lots of people had a go at this and it
turns out it took different approaches I
guess to solve this particular thing so
in the 1980s there was some work done
and a completely separate conjecture was
made by a guy called William Thurston
which was about kind of four dimensional
things and shapes and it turned out that
that was quite closely related to it but
that wasn't proved either and it took
until in 2003 at which point a
mysterious
cumin appeared on the internet which had
proof of Thurston's conjecture which
also proved the Poincare conjecture for
this unknown four-dimensional case it
was very exciting everyone was sort of
scrambling to try and try and find
whether this was a real proof or not
because the Poincare conjecture having
been around for so long was one of the
most falsely proved results in the
history of Matz like it's had more wrong
proof attempts than any other statement
which is brilliant because it means
people are trying really hard to solve
it actually this is one of the nice
things about the I'm thinking the nice
things about the this archive that
instantly God his work spread to
everybody I guess in the old days maybe
these things would be sent out as
preprints which of course I remember
those old days well but I don't know if
he would have had the resources to
spread it would have taken a lot longer
for people to realize that that this
stuff was out there the mathematical
community dived on this paper and
checked it and verified that it was in
fact a proof of what it claimed to me
and it was but I remember when Ben Chow
said this is amazing stuff we're gonna
now have a seminar and we met several
hours a week and we're going to study
this and each chapter this was it was
about a seven or eight chapter paper
we're each assigned a chapter but it
turned out that to understand a chapter
took huge amounts of work the
mathematician that had put this paper up
was called Grigori Perelman he was from
Russia and he was awarded a Fields Medal
which is like maths equivalent of a
Nobel Prize
he was also of course awarded the the
Millennium prize of a million dollars
and he for various reasons I guess
declined both of those things he didn't
necessarily want them the fact that he
did made an absolutely huge media storm
everyone was interested suddenly and he
he could have had any job anywhere in
the world after he did this but he
didn't want to take it and he's a bit of
a you know he wear his hair is funny and
he lives with his mother and sent
Petersburg or something I've actually
never met him
mathematician that solves difficult
question wasn't news but mathematician
that solved difficult question and
doesn't want a million dollars with
suddenly huge news for about a year
after after he put these papers out I
remember was November of 2002 because I
remember
was with a bunch of people who were
really into Ritchie flow in San Diego
and those papers came out and we
instantly just focused on trying to
understand those those those papers and
they're very very difficult
about for the year after that Perelman
did sort of a world tour I know some
friends in Berlin he came to visit them
near Berlin he came to MIT and gave some
talks and he did a bit of a tour and if
I wasn't busy teaching and then just
didn't have the time to really well
maybe I should have done it but any I
didn't go to see him at any of these
talks who knew that he was going to just
immediately let's say after a year go
back and go back into staying away from
from publicity it would be fun to meet
him I guess I've simplified it here and
is a little bit more complicated to
define specifically what I mean by each
of these things but hopefully that gives
you a rough idea of the kind of maths
that it's talking about there are a lot
more kind of difficult blackboards full
of squiggly numbers you know there are
different ways of doing math one way you
can take some big problem like that and
say I'm going to do just focus on that
the danger of that is you don't you
don't solve it and then you know that's
not so good or you can look at many many
different problems I like to look at
many different problems that not
focusing on one particular one but he
would take that problem fact from what I
understand from friends who knew him he
announced at some point I forget exactly
when many years before he actually came
out with these papers I'm gonna use
Ritchie flow to try to salt to try to
solve the Poincare conjecture and he
just without I don't know if he was
doing any teaching at the time but
living in San Petersburg and then he did
it
if you haven't seen already we've got a
video about Ricci flow and Ricci flow
surgery which is kind of like the golden
bullet that helped them solve the
Poincare conjecture if you haven't seen
them yet maybe go and have a look I'll
have links everywhere in all the usual
places we've also got a video about
another one of the Millennium problems
the Riemann hypothesis so maybe you
could go and watch that video that one
hasn't been solved yet so there's a
million dollars there for you if you can
crack it